You should always have a goal.
It's okay if you change that goal
at an every given time.
But you always need to ask yourself,
why do you do what you do.
Tomer Cohen,
thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good morning.
Thank you for having me, Michael.
It's great being here.
It is an honor and a pleasure
to have you.
All the way from the soccer field
from a year or two ago.
All the way now.
Look how far we've come, you see.
It's really really a pleasure
to have you here because you have
one of those unique journeys
that I can't wait to hear
your perspective on.
Going from the political scene,
from the spokesperson scene.
You are very very active
with various political campaigns
like Yesh Atid in Israel.
Or being the spokesperson of various
and really important figures.
Going to New York
and being the chief of staff
of the delegation to the UN.
And then, transitioning into
the business sector and running Jobit,
helping people find jobs across Israel.
And most recently, being the CEO
of the amazing company BUYME.
Tomer, give me a little bit of rundown
of that transition.
Why go into politics in the first place?
And what is the trigger
that pushes you more towards business?
Well, I actually I always knew
that I wanted to take part in business.
But right after the Army,
I did five years of military service.
Four of which in the paratroopers
and then one year
in the IDF spokesperson unit.
And then, when I was done with that
I had the dilemma of whether or not
I should go to study full time
or work full time.
And I felt like doing, you know,
such an amazing things in the Army,
I felt that I want to be part
of the action
and not only go to school and learn.
And when I, you know,
I took a look at my sets of skills
and sportsmanship was one of them.
I did not know anything
about business, entrepreneurship,
being a manager, nothing.
And when I look around
in the Israeli market,
I saw that there is an opening
in the Israeli Knesset,
in the Israeli parliament.
And so, I started my career there
knowing that eventually
I want to move into business.
But during that time, I studied my LL.B.
And I work fortunately
in the Israeli parliament.
So, again, I knew that
that would be the case in the end.
I actually, five years
after I started politics,
I wanted to do the transition.
And then I got the offer
to move to New York
and be, as you said,
chief of staff to the Israeli mission
to the United Nations.
And when that was done
and I came back to Israel,
that was like
a very natural choice for me.
Right.
So, tell me a little bit about
this spokesperson role.
Because it's a very unique role
that very few people hold, right?
I'm guessing there is not
too many spokespeople
for the different groups.
You've gotten to be spokesperson
both for individuals,
but you've also got to be a spokesperson
for a whole new political campaign,
Yesh Atid.
So, what is that role
and what are some of the responsibilities
that come with it?
Actually, the spokesperson part
was like, I think 18 months
of my seven years career
in the political and diplomatic sector.
So, during those 18 months, as you said,
I was a spokesman
for an Israeli parliament member.
And then a spokesman for,
you can say,
an Israeli political startup,
which was Yesh Atid back in the day.
Right. I love that term, yeah.
It was a startup
and it felt that way, you know.
A group of young people
trying to change the world.
And being a spokesperson
is pretty much knowing
what is the biggest advantage
of the person or the entity
you are trying to convey their message
into the public and making sure
that the public will know the good stuff,
the strengths, and make sure
that the weaknesses will be left behind.
And if, for some reason,
the media try to tackle them,
you provide the right answer.
So, it's basically conveying a message.
Very similar to marketing in a sense.
So, I did that for 18 months, as I said.
And then I moved into,
I will say, being a manager,
being someone who get things done
in the political and diplomatic sector.
So, I was the chief of staff
to the Israeli minister
of science and technology.
Former head of Shin Bet,
which is the Israel, you can say FBI.
And I learned a lot from him
for like almost two years.
And that prepared me for my,
I will say my biggest role at the UN,
which is basically
you know, it's representing our country
in the most hostile environment
diplomatic wise.
That is incredible.
Yeah.
So, you find yourself in New York
the Israeli mission
to the United Nations.
Give me the biggest challenge
that you had.
What was the most difficult thing
that you encountered?
Because, you know,
from our industry now,
very, very few people
are going to have a chance
to experience being in such
a difficult diplomatic scene.
So, paint me a little bit of a picture
of what was the most perhaps challenging
and also exhilarating part
of that whole journey.
So, I will try to use an analogy.
So, imagine you have a startup.
And you know your product is good.
It's amazing.
And you need to sell that product
to a specific market.
And no one in that market
is even willing to sit down
and have a conversation with you.
No one.
You find like two or three
good major clients
and you sell them your product
and they feel very confident about it
and they use it
and they are happy with it.
But then, when you try and take that
and broaden it
and move into the scale mode,
you just cannot because no one
is even taking the meeting.
And in that very strange,
weird situation,
you need to find a way
to get people to listen.
And that was, I think,
the main challenge.
To get people to listen to you
and be willing to learn
from what you have to say.
That's incredible.
I love that analogy.
Having a product, knowing that it's good,
having some major clients,
but the market is not willing
to even sit down and listen to you.
I could not have said better.
Tomer, that transition, Jobits.
You have done a few organizations,
now you are running BUYME.
If I look at both Jobit and BUYME,
they're very similar in the sense of
you're making people happy.
And it's not in the traditional way
of just sending them money
or sending them a gift basket.
But you're creating opportunities
for people, on one hand
you're creating job opportunities.
On the other hand,
you're creating opportunities for unity,
for a company-wide partnership.
And for people within the company
to gift others.
So, tell me a little bit about why Jobit
and then we'll move on to BUYME.
Sure thing.
So, when I came back to Israel,
I was debating whether or not
I should go into a big corporate.
I had a few offers
from big tech companies in Israel,
or should I start something by myself.
And I eventually decided
to become an entrepreneur
and actually found the company.
And my main issue was back then
that I wanted to make sure
that I as you said, I do good,
I want to make sure that the things I do
and the time I spend
will have some sort of
a good impact on people
and hopefully on society as well.
So, that's when I started Jobit.
Jobit is an innovative placement company
who puts their effort
on helping people grow
and manage their career.
We were focusing
on Gen-Y and Gen-Zed.
I'm part of that generation
so I can help.
I know exactly what they need
as far as career management is concern.
You know, we love to move around
from position to position,
from job to job.
A live [--] example.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
And I'm doing that for two years,
you know, building the company,
building the product, the brand,
bringing in the team
and building something that is unique
in the Israeli ecosystem
was an amazing experience.
And I felt like I was doing good,
and I learn a lot from the process.
And Jobit is still up and running.
It has a much better CEO
than myself right now running it.
And they're doing a very good job.
I love that.
You know, one of the things that I love
about this show is that
I get to take people like you
that have spent now
almost three years really
becoming an expert
on the Gen-Y, Gen-Zed market
of job seekers and career seekers.
And you get to now teach me
in a few minutes
everything that you've learned
or some things that you've learned
over those three years.
So Tomer, just hit me.
What are some insights
of Gen-Y and Gen-Zed job seekers
in the market?
Well, the way I look at it
and a lot of very smart people
did a lot of research
is that I had the chance of reading
in the States, in Israel.
And the main thing I learned is that,
you know in the past
when you started a job,
that job usually was,
again, I love analogies,
that job was the book
of your professional life.
So, you started in chapter one
and you move from chapter to chapter.
And at the end,
you can pretty much imagine what will be
the minute you start that job,
you can pretty much imagine
what's it going to look like in the end.
But our generation is different.
The way we act
is we act more in a chapter mode.
So, each time you decide
on a certain way
you want to tackle your career
and you spend a chapter there
if you're doing a good job.
So, it's like two years at a time.
And the hard part
is finding the connections
between the two chapters
to make sure
that you are always moving forward
and not moving to the side.
And that is why I started Jobit.
I wanted to help people
manage their career.
Create a career path
that will help them reach their goal.
And in most cases at the beginning,
they don't even know what their goal is.
The question is,
what do you want to do
when you grow up
and where do you see yourself
in five or 10 years time?
It's not part of the conversation.
No one ever thought
that this is something
we need to plan for.
Now, always when I said that,
your follow up question should be,
"Yeah, but how do you know
what you want to do
when you grow up?"
The world is full
of different possibilities.
And my take on that
is that you should always have a goal.
It's okay if you change that goal
at an every given time.
But you always need to ask yourself,
why do you do what you do.
Why do you spend your most
valuable asset, which is your time,
in that particular place
doing that particular thing.
And that is that is my main take
on our generation.
We need to plan ahead
and make sure we do
what needs to be done
in order to achieve our goals.
I couldn't agree more
and I have to follow through with it
with an analogy of my own.
I remember about four years ago
when I was attempting
to run a marathon
in Eilat and I remember
that my coach told me something
that really helped me
at the end finish it
was it doesn't really matter
what happens in these four hours.
You can't plan ahead and say,
my goal is to finish the marathon
in four hours.
Look at that tree
and run those 50 meters.
When you get to that tree, re-evaluate.
Do you want to make another goal
for another 50 meters?
You probably will
and then you'll make it.
If you plan too far
and you get stumbled along the way,
you lose sight of the bigger picture
and how those small steps
can be meaningful.
And I think that you know,
what you've done with the Jobit
is so inspiring.
And it's helped so many people.
That's a true positive impact.
Because I think that
I can speak freely for our generation.
And I'm a little bit younger than you
so, I think that I even feel more.
You know, we have no idea
where the world is going to end up
in 10, 15 years.
You know, we've accelerated in 2020
about 10, 15 years in the future already
in terms of digitalization.
You know, we're going to,
and I think McKinsey estimates
that we're going to be
changing our careers, our core career,
about three or four times
along our lifetime,
which is insane.
And so, having a place like Jobit
which can help you consolidate
your thoughts, set those milestones
and think more critically about
what type of person you want to be.
I love it.
Tomer, BUYME.
You transitioned from Jobit to BUYME.
You're going into an existing company.
Tell me why and what is BUYME?
Well, I think the main reason,
I'll take it in a different way.
First of all, BUYME
is an amazing company.
It has an amazing technological product
enables people and companies,
give gifts to the people they care about.
And just being part
of that kind of an environment
is addicting, really.
Because as I said at the beginning,
we do a lot of good.
In BUYME in our platform
in every less than a minute,
a gift is being send to someone.
And that's amazing.
The reason I did the transitioning
beside the opportunity to emerge
and I was approached
to take part in this company
is basically, I think the scale.
So, Jobit is an amazing company
with an amazing cause.
But it was relatively
small scale back then.
And today BUYME is like, I think
I don't know, 10 or 15 or 20 times bigger
in employees, impact, P&L,
everything that is in the zone of
managing the company.
And I love mechanisms.
I'm a manager
and I love setting up mechanism
who can create an impact on people,
on the people I manage,
my employees, my team.
And that opportunity when it emerged,
I had no doubt that this is,
this should be my next chapter.
[--]
I love it.
So, you mentioned that
BUYME is about gifting.
In every minute somebody gets a gift,
which is, by the way, incredible.
And I can, you know, at the end,
when we talk about entrepreneurship,
I think that at the end
it comes down to
what can make you feel fulfilled
to sleep at night well.
And I would love going to sleep knowing
that I'm running a company
whose product is that
every single minute
somebody is getting a happy gift
and is putting a smile on their face.
What is this gifting process?
And why is it different or innovative
from the traditional gifting
where I can call ZER4U
or a flower shop
and just send a gift basket
to my employees?
Which was how
it was done five, 10 years ago
traditionally.
Yeah. So, BUYME
he's been around for about eight years.
And back then,
when they started the company,
the original entrepreneurs
together with a group,
business group called Teleclal
who is actually the owner
of BUYME today, that was exactly
the question people ask them,
"Why do I need this?"
You know, there is a lot
of different opportunities
and possibilities to give people gifts
and employees gifts.
And the answer was
that our generation is different.
We want to have the ability
to choose our gifts.
And you saw more and more people
in the private sector
and even in the business sector,
instead of giving gifts to people
they started giving money.
If it's holidays, yeah,
you can buy whatever you want.
If it's in the workplace, yeah,
you'll just get this or that bonus
at the end of the month
because you did a good job
or even if you had a birthday.
And the reason is that
the essence of being able to choose
is very important.
And this is you know,
this is our generation,
this is the time we're living in, 2020
than back then in 2012.
And BUYME saw that.
And using technology,
we have an R&D center
of about 20 employees,
using technology,
we were able to connect
more than 1200 businesses
all across Israel.
Wow.
And using one unique code
you were able to use that gift
in any one of those 1200 businesses.
And BUYME, you know,
started the process
of getting people more and more adjusted
and into this new way of giving gifts
and making people happy.
And today we have
about 5,000 business customers,
business clients, companies,
who give gifts
to about one million Israelis.
And we actually started three years ago,
our private sector platform in which
we have hundreds of thousands
of Israelis who give gifts
to the people they care about,
whether it's birthday
someone gave birth, holidays, etc.
And the ability to do something
that is personal,
meaning you can, you know,
you can use our platform
and send them a video, a photo,
you can obviously, you write them
a very personal something
that they will know
what you think about them
and why you are giving them
this particular present.
And all of this created
a personal process
in which people are receiving gifts
and are happy to use them.
And it's amazing.
I think that's remarkable.
And it's one of the things
that I'm always very curious
about this transition.
Because effectively, you know,
you could say here, just take money,
use that money
as the global currency
to buy whatever you want.
But money is not a gift, right?
Money is not personal.
Money is not,
there's no emotions connected to money.
Yet, you're creating this currency
that is emotional,
that is connected to the gift process
of saying, I appreciate you.
I'm not just giving you a bonus,
but I'm appreciating you
for all the hard work
and for the person that you are.
And you're allowing that currency
to be translated
into all these businesses.
And I think that's just such a smart
and innovative way
of thinking about our culture
and our traditions.
You know, the currency
is even more than a gift.
The currency and the term we use
is an experience.
We give you the chance to get
a positive experience in your life.
Not many people, not many companies,
can say they do exactly that.
It doesn't matter if you get a gift card
and you choose to use it
to buy something in a H&M, okay.
You can use it to whatever.
You can go to a luxury restaurant.
You can go to a vineyard.
You can do a tour in Tel Aviv
and enjoy the scene.
You can do a lot of different things.
But again, at the essence
is you give a gift
which is actually an experience.
And you create positive moments
in the people you care about in life.
And again, that's amazing.
I love it.
Positive impact on the people,
positive impact on the businesses.
I just love it.
Tomer, thank you so much
for being so generous with your time.
This was just amazing.
And I love that I finally got to learn
about your past life,
which is a full life on its own
for the average person.
So, it's really remarkable.
So, thank you for everything
that you've done for Israel.
Thank you for everything
you're doing now, for the economy
and for job seekers
and the younger generations.
And for gifting to people all over Israel
and eventually the world.
Before we leave,
I have the final question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
I did not think ahead.
So, you know, let's just do this.
The first word is two word
but I combined them with a dash.
So, that's fine I think is do-good.
Of course.
Do good.
The second word is plan.
And as I said, always have a plan.
Plan ahead.
And the third word,
which is actually the first word,
if I had to be completely honest, family.
I love that.
And anybody who's in touch
with you and follow the social media
and you can see
the pictures behind you.
Beautiful kids.
Congratulations on building
such a beautiful family.
And thank you for being
such an inspiration.
Thank you.
Thank you very much
for having me, Michael.
Thank you.